you ready for me to go into some
meet I believe the word is
amnos let me double check amnos now
those of you who read the Greek version
of the Old Testament Isaiah
53 John is
indicating this is the
one whom the Lord announced here you go
what does it mean okay watch here you
ready watch the
connection a sacrificial lamb used for
sacrifice a young sheep without blemish
especially a one-year-old lamb
one-year-old lamb okay can refer to that
or can refer to sacrificial Lambs in
general okay watch here
strongs New Testament 286 amnos amnos o
from Sophocles and
Aristo down a lamb acts 8:32 1 Peter
1119 to theu consecrated to God John 1
12936 in these passages Christ is
likened to a sacrificial lamb on account
of his death innocently and patiently
endured to expiate sin see Aron why is
he called omnos because if you read
Isaiah 53 let me show you quoted in Acts
8 acts
to35 the Holy Spirit tells philli attach
yourself to that Chariot there's an
Ethiopian unit reading Isaiah 53 and the
spirit said to Philip go up and join
this Chariot so Philip ran to him and
heard him reading Isaiah the prophet and
asked him do you understand what you're
reading and your beginning stages when
you're a babe on milk what does the Holy
Spirit do for you you understand what
you're reading and he said how can I
unless someone guides me this man was
humble enough you see God loves
humbleness humble yourself he'll exalt
you exalt yourself will humble you this
man was humble enough to realize I don't
know I don't know what it means
you see it right there how can I know
unless someone guides me I don't know
what it means Lord I don't understand
I'm
confused Lord I don't want to
misunderstand I want to know you I want
to handle this word because I'll be
responsible if I don't understand Lord
please when you pray those prayers and
you humble
yourself and admit to God I don't know
and I'm not qualified the spirit in his
love will say don't worry I've heard
your cries I'm the one with you and
guiding you here man of God teach him
man of God be my mouthpiece instruct him
man of
God help him to
grow see how beautiful your Bible
is it's moving me my spirit to be honest
with you because the Lord did that for
me spite of my imperfections and sins in
the 90s when I cried out to know his
word and to help me understand in his
love for me he heard me
see man of
God
teacher say what I prayed in the 90s
when I was lost but the Lord worked
differently he didn't bring me a human
teacher I didn't have a bishop or a
pastor no one discipled me the
spirit taught me in a unique way
sorry just you know thinking about how
beautiful and good the spirit is to me
and to all of us the Same Spirit who
loves me he's in love with you he loves
us equally may he fill us and help me
and save me he is my comp I trust in him
my life is
his sorry just thinking how he's been
with me and still with
me and he hasn't abandoned
me he hasn't abandoned
me but now watch why did John say Lamb
of God why did John say Lamb of God
watch here here it is quoting Isaiah
53 okay now the passage of the scripture
which he was reading was this as a sheep
L to the slaughter or a lamb before its
Shear is DB that's why Isaiah 53 said
the servant of God will be like a lamb
let to be slaughtered so when John the
Baptist says Behold the Lamb of God he's
saying here he is the one of Isaiah
53 the one who would come die for our
sins bear our sins atone for our sins be
raised to life to intercede for us and
save us forever that's him Israel that's
the Lamb of God of Isa 53 right there
the word lamb so he opens not his mouth
in his humiliation Justice was denied
him who can describe his generation
because he was cut off didn't get
married didn't have children but now
he's alive forever in glorified flesh
and his wife is the church a spiritual
bride not a physical one no sex and the
children are the children of God that
he's purchased by his blood for his life
was taken up from the earth and the unic
watch the humbleness of the unic see if
you come like the unic and you humble
yourself like the
unic the Lord will exalt you unic said
to Philip about whom pray does the
prophet say this who is he talking about
is it about himself or about someone
else now watch the man of God filled
with the spirit what does he do bring
all glory to Jesus no attention himself
then Philip opened his mouth and
beginning with this scripture he told
him the good news of
Jesus the good news of Jesus you caught
it
so you see what John the Baptist was
telling you there is the Lamb of Isaiah
who dies to take away the sin of the
world Isaiah
53 there's another
connection this is the other
connection okay Genesis 22 7- 14 Genesis
22 7- 14 now watch
here another
connection and Isaac said to his father
Abraham my father he said here I am here
am my my son he said behold the
fire and the wood but where's the
lamb the lamb for a burnt offering
Abraham said God will provide himself
the lamb for a burnt offering my son
don't worry about it God will provide so
they went both of them together now
here's what's
ironic it wasn't a lamb it was a ram but
a ram is not a lamb and Abraham lifted
up his eyes and looked and behold behind
him was a ram
caught in a Thicket by his horns and
Abraham went and took thean and offered
it up as a burnt offering instead of his
son that's not a lamb that's a ram but
then he calls that place Jehovah Gyra
because on this mountain Jehovah will
provide for himself Genesis 22:14 why
because the lamb was yet to come when
John the
Baptist said Behold the Lamb of God who
takes away the sin of the world that's
the lamb that Abraham said God would
provide for himself there he is Abraham
there he is Isaac there he is Isaiah
there he is the Lamb of God sent to take
away the sin of the world there he is so
Abraham called the name of that place
that mountain yahwah Jehovah Gyra as it
is said to this day on the mount this
Mount Jehovah will Prov be provided he
will provide for himself which later on
became the Temple Mount which became a
picture of Christ that's why John said
the Lamb of God the lamb that Abraham
said Jesus would would be the lamb that
Abraham said God would provide the lamb
that Isaiah said would be led to the
slaughter for our sins you see how deep
this Bible is now a ram is not a lamb
now but let me explain to you why a ram
was provided a ram has two horns a ram
has two horns what does a horn represent
you don't need to guess Revelation
17:12 Revelation
1712 a horn represents a king with power
and a kingdom Revelation 17:12 here it
is a horn means a king with power and a
kingdom and the 10 horns you saw
Revelation 1712 are 10 Kings see a horn
is a king who have not yet received
royal power they're going to be given
power eventually but they are to receive
Authority as kings for one hour together
with the Beast so what is a horn a king
so why a Ram with two horns because this
Ram is a picture of Jesus right this Ram
is a picture of Jesus okay let me show
it to
you two horns because Jesus is king of
Heaven and
Earth the king of heaven and earth king
of Jews and Gentiles because in the
the world is divided in two Jews
Gentiles Heaven and Earth the ram who's
the king of Heaven king of earth king of
Israel King of the Nations but now
notice this Ram is caught in a
Thicket and then he died in the place of
Isaac so Isaac could be spared what is a
Thicket a thorn
bush his head was caught in a thorn bush
what did they do to
Jesus they put on his head a crown of
thorns like the ram whose head was
caught in a thorn bush Jesus king of
heaven and earth king of the Jews and
the Nations had a crown of thorns placed
on his head the ram a picture of Jesus
to come